welcome to best practices for text on
Android my name is Cara Valeri and I'm a
tech lead on the Android toolkit team
I'm Frida Martinez and I'm gonna Android
developer advocates see I'm its inner
takes lead for Android text so why are
we giving a talk about text well it
turns out text is a major part of your
app it's part of your design it's part
of your branding it's part of who you
are and it is the major thing that your
users will be consuming it is fun front
the first thing that your users will
read and the thing that will mostly
affect readability accessibility
usability all of that on top of that the
Android text sack is responsible for
emoji which we all love but all of this
obviously comes at a cost and so there's
a bunch of performance implications
related to text that we want you to be
aware of and so today we're gonna go
through a bunch of best practices and
things that you should know before we
can do that let's talk a bit about the
architecture we want to explain how the
text stack is fitted with an Android so
you can better then understand what
we're gonna talk about later the tech
stack on Android is split into two parts
there's Java code and then there's
native or C++ code at the very top of
the Java layer you'll find the thing
that you're probably most familiar with
which is text view and edit text these
are widgets that provide text
functionality out of the box and do
everything for you if you have custom
views where you don't want to use our
widget then you're probably using the
second layer which is layout paint in
canvas this class is on Java will help
you layout text and render it without
actually using our widget once we get
into the native part the very first
layer is a library we call minikin
minikin helps us do word measurement
line breaking and hyphenation
and it is our first point of contact
with C++ below that there's a bunch of
libraries we use to help us ICU which
deals with Unicode harf buzz which does
text shaping for us free type which
generates bitmaps for all of the glyphs
and finally skia which is our graphics
engine today we're gonna focus on the
top three as these are the layers that
the Android team owns and the one we can
provide most best practices and hints
into
mimicking lies at the core of Android
tech stack and is implemented in C++
it's many sponsibility czar text layout
measurement and line breaking it is
important to understand what parts are
implemented in minikin versus Java as
that defines which features we can back
port using support library which doesn't
allow native code let's start with text
measurement if we provide a string like
this Dominican first it has to identify
the glyphs glyph is a representation of
a character and you can think of it as
the image to be drawn however the
character to glyph matching is not
always one to one here we have three
letters FF I matching to a single leaf
glyphs can also be found in different
forms which is the case with the
Japanese character in the example this
is called the font fallback chain once
all the glyphs are identified the system
can position them together to have the
final look however at this point
positioning is not always putting the
glyph side-by-side which is the case
with the letter e an acute accent if we
provide a longer string mini can first
divide it into words and for each word
it does the measurement the result of
this measurement is added into a cache
so that if the system comes across with
the same word again it can range the
computed value this is a system-wide LRU
cache and has a fixed size of 5000 items
when the string is wider than the array
it has to fit an minikin has today a
line break in the simplest case this is
putting the box's side by side until the
boundary is reached and then moving to
the next line the behavior is controlled
with the break strategy at ribbit and if
we were to switch from simple to
balanced here minikin will distribute
the words among the lines to have better
text alignment the default value is high
quality which is very similar to
balanced except a few subtle differences
one of them being hyphenation for the
last line high finishing improves the
alignment of the text and the use of
white space and it gets more and more
important as the line bit gets shorter
however it comes with a cost the coast
arises because now the system has to
measure more words and it has to come
more configurations for an optimum
solution app to Android P enabling
hyphenation is two-and-a-half times more
expensive than the disabled state on
Android P we improved the simple break
strategy case however the default
configuration still has the same cost
another thing that affects hyphenation
is the locale in this example we have a
device in the English local and two
example strings one of them is not
hyphenated correctly and the other one
did not choose the right kliff for the
japanese text this will mostly happen
for dynamically loaded text such as
these things loaded from network and it
happens because the system is not aware
of the languages of those strings to fix
this we have to tell the system about
the language using the set text locale
function if these three contains
multiple languages you can use locale
span to mark different parts of the
world string however keep in mind that
the number of locale spans affects the
performance of the text layout one of
the most common tasks when working with
text is text styling so usually we would
start working with the text view
attributes and set the text size text
color and font so we call this a single
style because all of these attributes
affect the entire text from the text
view but usually for the designers this
is not enough and they will want to
style specifically one word or one
paragraph so what they want is to apply
a multiple style to the same style to
the same text block so in order to
achieve this in Android we work with
spans spans our markup objects that can
be attached to text from a start to an
end index and spans can be categorised
into character and paragraph spans
depending on whether they apply to only
a few characters or to entire paragraphs
and then character spans can be split
into appearance and metric effecting and
the difference between them lies in the
method that needs to be called on the
textview
in order to render the slide at the side
so a appearance affecting spans require
a redraw to be called
whereas
metric affecting expands required both
remeasure and a redraw let's see an
example so let's say that we need to
style a code block so in order to do
this first we would change the
background color so for this we would
use a background color span this doesn't
change the metric of the of the text so
this means this is an appearance
affecting span but we also need to
change the font so for this for this we
would use a typeface span but because
phones also change the size of the text
this is a matrix affecting span to style
blocks of text by for example changing
the layout margin or drawing a bullet in
front of the text we would use a bullets
span so paragraph spans like the bullet
span have to be attached from the
beginning of the paragraph and affect
the entire text of the paragraph the
thing is that if you don't attach it
from the beginning of the paragraph well
chances are you'll lose the styling
completely so in in the framework we
define a series of interfaces and
abstract classes and under the hood the
framework checks for instances of these
classes and then triggers different
actions depending on them but actually
what makes spans so powerful is the fact
that they give you access to things like
the text paints or the canvas in the
case of some paragraphs pants so this
means that you can pretty much handle
everything you need in terms of text so
first of all whenever you need a span
check the ones that are available in the
framework because they cover most of the
common use cases okay but if we go back
to our example we see that the typeface
span only gets a typeface starting with
Android P so this means that if we want
to support pre P devices we will need to
create our own custom span so to do this
we would extend from metric affecting
span and this class gives us access to
two methods to update measure state
which is called when textview on measure
is called an update draw state which is
called when that takes view on draw
method is called and both of these
methods give us access to the text paint
so then in the
explained all we need to do is change
the typeface but if we have the text
pane it means that we can also set the
background color so it means that we can
just create one code block span to style
our code block okay so now we have two
different ways of styling our code block
one with composing multiple spans one
from the framework and a custom one and
another one
where we're using a custom span so which
one should you use to help you decide
there's one important piece of
information that you need to remember
only framework spans can be parcel so
there are two common cases when the
spans are parcel first when we're
passing text via intents or when we're
copying text independently for copying
text for example from a text view to an
edit text in the same activity or
whether we're copying text from one
application to another the text gets to
be parceled and unperson we are the
clipboard service so this is what will
happen if we're passing the text with
one framework spent and one custom span
well just our framework spans our past
so this means that we're losing our
custom typeface plan but then if we're
passing a text with one custom span that
it means that no styling will be kept
so in general when you're implementing
spans and the text gets far so consider
the behavior you want should the style
be partially kept or not so now that you
know that spans how do we use them in
text well the framework provides two key
interfaces for this the first one is
spanned spend is for immutable text and
immutable markup and declares methods
such as get spans or it gets spent start
and get spent end it lets you query
spans but not modify them if you want to
modify them we have span a ball which
has the ability to mutate the markup
with methods to test set span or remove
span then we have three concrete
implementations of these interfaces the
first one is span string which
implements spanned and as such has
immutable text an immutable markup
spannabis string which implements
spammable
as such has immutable textbook mutable
market and finally we have a third class
which adds mutable
the text with the spannabis
stringbuilder this is what we use
internally for example for edit text
because it allows you to modify the text
and the markup these last two classes
are very different internally spannabis
string holds an array of spans whereas
venable string builder holds a tree of
spans so these are widely differently
implemented so as a team we were
wondering well is the tree more
efficient maybe there's a case where we
want to recommend people to only use
findable string or string builder all
the time because it's more efficient so
we ran tests the answer is up to 250
spans they're the same
they basically perform equally so we
recommend you do what makes most
semantic sense which is use spannabis
string for immutable text spannabis
string builder for mutable text however
after 250 spans they really do start to
diverge and we recommend you use Manimal
string builder for all of your cases
just because it is more performant out
of curiosity we ran these tests to the
limit and turns out when you have
thousands of spans they really diverge
but we really really hope this is not a
common use case for anyone another
common thing we see with spans is people
trying to check if one span is present
within a span able and the solution
we've seen online uses span get spans so
it's something like this you just query
for all the spans of a given type get an
array back and then just check if the
array is empty this is extremely
inefficient you're going through the
entire span looking for all of the
instances of that span collecting them
all into an array and then just checking
if that array is empty there's a better
way to do this which is next span
transition this method checks for the
boundaries of spans so when you ask for
the first boundary of a certain span it
will just have to do the work until it
sounds the first man and then it can
stop and it won't collect any spans into
an array wasting memory that you
shouldn't do a frequent task when
working with styling text is styling
internationalized text so usually in
your resources you will define the same
string in multiple languages but then
you need to highlight one specific word
so here for example we want the word
text to be bold but the thing is that
the word and where it appears is
different in every language so one easy
solution would be to just use HTML tag
but the problem and this is that HTML
tags have limited functionality so if
for example we want to change the font
well this is not something that HTML can
provide the solution for this is to use
a notation tags so the annotation tag
allows us to set key and value pairs and
then define whatever we need so here for
example I'm defining in the key font and
the value to be the font name and this
is how we would use it in code so we
would get the text from the resources as
a spammed string then we would get the
annotations from the span we would eat
right through them and get the ones that
have the key that we're interested in
and then the value and then we would set
the span based on the indices we will
now look at how text is laid out in the
view let's assume that you have a text
with some padding applied when you set
the roll top text we will position the
image to top of the view after the
padding get compound padding top
function will return you the distance
from top of the view to bottom of the
image setting the Drobo padding will add
extra spacing between the image and the
area that the text will be drawn in and
now get compound padding top will point
to this new location when you set text
text we will create a layout object
layout is responsible for rendering and
measuring text here the boundaries of
the layout are highlighted in orange it
will also provide you some more
information about the text it contains
such as the baseline and top and bottom
of the lines there are three layout
classes on Android boring clay out is
for single style and simple text which
doesn't contain tab next line or
right-to-left characters dynamic layout
is created for editable and selectable
text and for other cases text we will
create a static layout when you set the
gravity the layout object itself will be
positioned in the wheel get total
padding tab will return a the distance
from top of the wheel to the top of the
layout include foam padding this
attribute will add extra spacing to top
and bottom of the layer
and the value the height of this spacing
is calculated using the values in the
font the effect is more visible than you
use at all script in this example when
it is set to false we see that the text
is clipped since it only applies when
you set to true it only applies the
spacing to top and bottom of the text on
Android we will see that lines would
overlap on Android P will fix this issue
now if the system identifies that the
text the lines will overlap it will put
extra spacing between the lines and will
apply this rule to the whole paragraph
to provide a knob to provide an opt-out
option we added an attribute named
fallback line spacing which is by
default turned on a similar attribute
that changes the line height is the
elegant text height attribute however
unlikely even though it changes the
light height unlike the other attributes
it will not add spacing but it will
actually start using a different font
there are two different fonts defined in
the Android font fallback chain compact
an elegant setting elegant excited to do
will make the system choose the elegant
version of the same script if that font
exists speaking of line height it is an
important attribute for the readability
of the text and you can control it using
line spacing extra and multiply that
Rivage these attributes will add extra
spacing in between the lines but not the
last line since these developers mention
does just that designers would mostly
provide line height as it is but not as
multiplier or extra on Android P we
added the line height attribute to other
attributes that we added on Android P in
order to bridge the gap between design
and implementation our first base line
to top height and last base line to
bottom height the first one will let you
control the distance between the top of
the view to the base line of the first
line and the second one similarly will
let you control the distance between
bottom of the view to the base line of
the last line finally when you said
takes alignment the take
we'll be positioned in the layout get
line left and get line read functions of
the layout object will give you
information about this positioning
relative to the layout boundaries now
that you know about layout and some
important functions we can answer a
frequently asked question on the
Internet
which is how to implement the rounded
background span this is not doable with
spans but we can implement it we can
draw it ourselves
using the layout functions to do that
first we need to mark our words that we
want to draw the background for a
notation that Florina mentioned is a
good option for such a use case then we
will define our Drobo's three for the
words that start and end on different
lines and one for diverge that start and
end on the same line we will loop over
our annotations to find our verge then
for each annotation using the start and
end indices we want to learn the line
number and we can use getline for offset
function of the layout which will
convert the character index into a line
number for the words that start and end
on the same line we also want to learn
about the vertical coordinates of the
line we can use get lined up and get
line bottom functions for this and
finally we want to learn about the
horizontal coordinates of the words and
get primary horizontal function will
convert the character index to a
horizontal coordinate relative to the
layout boundaries now that we know the
rectangle that we want to draw in we can
reward robell the other case where words
start and end on the different line will
have almost exactly the same code except
now it has to identify more rectangles
to draw in textview goes through the
same three phases that any of you on
android goes measure layout and draw
measure is by far the most expensive for
textview here is where we create the
layouts we just talked about or recreate
them if we need to and where we decide
on the width and the height of the view
this is really expensive work later and
on layout we'd barely do anything to
some scrolling and auto sizing and
finally an on draw we issue the drawing
commands but measure is really really
expensive
and you need to be very aware of this
it's important to distinguish what
causes an unmeasured with what causes an
Andhra and Serena mentioned before
anything that causes the text to change
in size or how it needs to be laid out
such as the letter spacing the typeface
maybe the text size that will have to
trigger an on measures we need to
recalculate that layout whereas if you
change something that just changes the
appearance but not how we place the text
on the screen such as the text color
you're gonna paint it in that only needs
to trigger an on draw which is much much
cheaper than doing an on measure as well
let's look at these two phases
separately say we have a text be like
this I've set some text that has several
paragraphs and then I've used spans to
style some of the words in it I've
changed the text size I've changed the
colors well the first option to measure
your text is there's method in paint
called measure text a dead giveaway of
this method is it takes a string not a
span a ball so what this will do paint
just doesn't understand spans so it will
take the text you've given it it doesn't
understand line breaking either so it
will place all of the text is one very
long line ignore all of your spans and
give you the width of that text the next
option is to use get text bounds also
from paint again
dead giveaway it takes a string so it
will do exactly the same no line
breaking those fans it will place it all
together and it will give you the
bounding box of all of your glyphs which
is a width and a height it's important
to notice that these two methods return
slightly different values so text paint
measure text will return you the next
advance glyph this is where you will
position the next glyph if you were to
add another one whereas get text bounds
will give you the bounding box of the
glyphs you have and these two values
come from different parts of the font so
they may be very different if we want to
improve on this well we use layouts
layout has a static method called get
desired width what this does is it takes
a text you give it it places each
paragraph into one line and taking into
account all of the styling it measures
each of the lines and then it returns
the width of the longest line it has so
it will give you the width of the
longest paragraph you've given it this
is useful to know how much your text
wants to be before you can restrict it
if you know the width of your view well
then you actually create a layout object
in this case we've created a static
layout by having the constraint width
you want to fit it in layouts can
actually calculate how to reflow the
text and how to make it fit and give you
a height in return so by giving it a
width we can actually calculate the
height on top of that as you haven't
mentioned before you will get a lot more
information out of your layout object
for each line it will give you things
like the baseline the lines start the
line end and so on we've measured the
performance of all of these methods next
to each other measure text is the
cheapest so compared to measure text you
will see that layout get desired width
and paint get text bounds are quite
cheap to run they are similar but once
you get into creating a static layout or
once you exit X for you to measure text
that gets more and more expensive so now
that you know what each of these methods
do make sure you use the one that makes
sense for your use case similarly we've
talked before about the word measure
cache and how we measure words once and
we place them in a cache well for paint
when you call measure text on the same
word a second time turns out it only
costs us about three percent of the work
to return that value which is a huge
gain so once we have a hit in the cache
it's only three percent of the work if
we measure this in text view on measure
takes about 16 to 11 percent of the work
that it did the first time it sees a
word
so definitely using that cache is really
important for us so as I said several
times now measurement is really
expensive what can we do about it well
in P we've come up with a new feature
called pre measured text the idea behind
it is we know that in on measure we need
to take all of the glyphs find them in
the font place them next to each other
and measure all of these words that we
will place in the cache so what P
measure text does is it takes care of
this phase for you and you can run this
in any thread so that then once you have
that pre calculation sending it on the
textview only takes about 10% of the
work that you had to do initially which
is a huge gain the way this looks in
code is we first we need a bunch of
attributes to know how to measure the
text things like the font you're going
to use the text size we have a
convenience method in the text view that
will retrieve all of these for you it's
get text metrics params you can also
build this option
self if you don't have the text we were
gonna work with yet and then on a
background thread called precomputed
text create this triggers all of the
things we've been talking about it
measures each of the words it places
them in the cache and it stores all of
those values so this is also useful if
you're gonna measure more than 5,000
words as this actually stores all of the
values then once you have all of this
pre computed information you can go back
to the UI thread and set it on your text
view notice that all of this only makes
sense if you know your text beforehand
if you just know your text as you're
gonna render it do what we've always
done because you're gonna be blocking
the UI thread anyway but if you do know
your text beforehand say you're loading
it from the internet or you have an
infinite scroll you can run this pre
compute all of your text before it needs
to be shown on screen and the gain is
literally 90% of the work will be done
on the background thread which is
amazing mention in support library we do
have a solution for P we just run this
between L and P we can actually not do
exactly the competitions that we've done
but we can warm up that cache for you so
that's what we do and then before L
sadly we can't do anything so it's a no
op but we do have a solution in the
support libraries another common thing
we see related to all of this is very
long text people tend to just say oh
I've got the text I'll just set it all
on the text view when you set text on
text view in layouts and well it
measures all of the words and lays out
the entire text you've given it even if
you've given us like an entire book so
this can be a huge performance hit if
you're sitting very long text but then
you're not actually showing on screen
because maybe the user never Scrolls a
solution to this is to split your text
into separate pieces say for example
paragraphs and put them all into a
recycler view as different items then
this way while the user Scrolls we will
start loading the next bits but we won't
actually be triggering and measuring a
layout of all of your text you can also
link this to premature text which I just
talked about and pre measure all of the
background measurement then you will
have all that information really really
efficiently so we've talked about
measure what about draw draw is much
cheaper but you also have several
options if you're gonna draw yourself
easy one that people tend to say oh why
don't you just canvas
draw text that's easy right turns out
canvas does not understand spans or line
breaking or any of the things we've been
talking about so similar to the things
we're talking about before it will just
draw the text you give it with no
styling as one run instead if you have
styling or if you want to use line
breaking again use the layout classes
you can see the recurring theme all of
the layout classes have a draw method
that will actually draw on the campus
for you okay I think it's time we
actually said the text but in a
performant way so set text I think is
the most commonly used method and it's
great for text views that don't change
so when both the text and the markup
attached to it are immutable so under
the hood the text we create a defensive
copy as a span string so this means that
if you're changing the original
reference the textview doesn't update
but what if we want to mutate the spans
later or to do this we would set the
text using buffer types pineapple so
under the hood the text we will create a
copy of it but as a parable so this
means that while the text is immutable
the spans are mutable so then once what
we can do here is we can get the text as
a span of all and then we can add or
remove spans to it and I know that
you'll be tempted to call that a set
text again but you don't need to do this
anymore because text view has an own
span change listener and it
automatically knows when something was
added or removed and the text will just
be displayed but what if you want to
change an internal property of the span
so in our case we want to change that
typeface in our custom typefaces fine
well in this case the textview doesn't
know what's changed and it doesn't know
that it needs to do something so we need
to tell it and we will do this with
either request layout or invalidate
depending on what kind of attribute has
changed so if you change the measure
affecting attribute and the textview
needs to remeasure and then redraw you
would call request layout but if you
just changed an appearance affecting
attribute then you just need to
invalidate and call redraw
what if you also want to mutate the text
so if we look at the code we see that
under the hood the text we craz a copy
using a span of olfactory so it has a
default span of all factory
implementation but we can implement our
own and then instead of creating a copy
of it we will just return the same
reference to the object in case the
object is expandable and then we just
said that span of a factory to the
textview so this is specifically
important if you're using style text
inside a recycler view because like this
you avoid creating copies inside the
recycler view saving both CPU time and
memory location so in the recycle view
this is how you would use it in the view
holder you would set the span of a
factory you've just created and then in
the own bind view holder make sure
you're also setting the buffer type as
spendable when you're setting the text
another common thing we see related to
recyclerview is the use of auto link you
might be familiar with like taking a
textview and just sitting out a link to
say web to be able to detect URLs within
your text and have them automatically
linked well what happens under the hood
when you do this turns out that when you
set a text on that textview first of all
we will create a copy just like Florina
said and then we run a matcher for a
regular expression on your text and for
each match where we find a URL we will
create a URL span and add that to your
text if you do this inside on bind
viewholder
you're creating copies and you're
running that regular expression every
time you're setting text even if you're
showing the same text in each item so
you have a little footer with a link
you're gonna be recalculating that for
each and every item so the solution to
this is one don't use auto link in your
XML because that automatically triggers
all of the process instead first of all
create a span of a copy of your strength
and run either link a fire link if I
compat to be able to find all those
links beforehand so you pre calculate
all of it then in online view holder you
simply have to set the text and if you
use fluorine as trick of using buffer
types pineapple you will be available
all of those copies and avoiding all of
this extra computation
related to this in general we want to
discourage everyone from using auto link
map
all of the other options in Auto link
used regular expressions and are easy to
run however a map actually spins off an
instance of a webview to find addresses
which is a huge performance hit for your
app so we wanted to scourge everyone
from using map or all which includes map
and you might say well but I need this
and you're taking it away what do I do
coming to the rescue is smart link if I
you might remember last year we
presented smart selection in o where we
use machine learning to detect entities
when you were trying to select text well
this year we've taken those missing
machine learning models that detect
entities and apply them to link if I
this way we can do a much better
accuracy at detecting all of the
entities and we can detect new types so
on top of phone numbers URLs and
addresses like we're doing before we can
do more sophisticated things like flight
codes the way this works in code is you
create a text links request with your
text and it can also take some options
then on a background thread you call
text classifier not generate links it's
very important that you do this on a
background thread as this is loading a
machine learning model from disk so
please don't do this on the UI thread
once it comes back it has all of the
detected entities you can apply those
links to the text there's a change here
between the old link if I and this the
olenka file used to generate a URL span
that when you clicked it would just go
through the link and the case of smart
link if I the URL spends that are being
added pop up a floating toolbar with
smart actions that you can take so for
example for an address we might suggest
Maps finally when you have all of your
text ready you can go back to the UI
thread and set that text on the text
view notice there's a big difference
between the old link if I and the new
link if I and that the old one was
synchronous and this is asynchronous we
understand this is a huge difference but
it is the way that we can use machine
learning to really enhance how we detect
entities and the accuracy on the new
models is really really much better and
since I'm talking about new features let
me introduce our last new feature for P
which is magnifier a lot of people tell
us that selecting text is really hard
and placing the cursor where you want is
a really hard task
so magnifier shows a zoomed in version
of where you are touching with your
finger to help you place the cursor in
the correct position we've implemented
this by default in text
edittext and in webview in chrome so you
don't have to do any work if you're
using the default widgets however if
you're doing your own custom widgets and
you want to do implement that this
yourself there's a very easy API to use
there you could do something like this I
just take your untouchable and whenever
the finger goes down show the magnifier
whenever the finger goes up dismiss the
magnifier this creates an effect where
the magnifier kind of follows your
finger around the screen this is not the
final UX we've gone for we kind of snap
to the lines and we will publish
guidelines on the final UX we've come up
with but it is very easy to use so I
hope today we've presented a bunch of
tips and tricks we've shown you what
text is under the hood and Android and
we've provided more information on how
to style your text so that you can take
all of this back to your apps and build
beautiful more performant apps
[Music]
[Applause]